well regardless of how the match goes we
hope that's the interest of the [__]
continues
on social media showing everybody the
tweet right now you guys have had some
fun going back and forth
so are you know i know i know it's all
in fun and jest
oh my gosh oh there's the man oh my god
i thought we were about to end uh-oh
okay first of all um
can i call you can i call you mister
instead of mr beast
oh sure whatever you want whatever you
want
these chess.com clowns okay and let's
just call them what they
are feeding content hit me in the dms
they go hey
do you want to hop on to talk on mr
beast
[Laughter]
bigger man i said no no this guy look
he's a little bit
nervous like come on busy man i don't
want to do this to him
come to find out you're on here talking
[__] calling me one trick pony
all right at one point what is this what
is this mister
i thought we had a thing going on i
thought this was like a there's a
friendly bout
what i didn't call you one trick pony
they called you one i did
i did and you didn't call danny dumb and
stupid for it but she is
i mean to be very yeah we'll see
okay what so so like out of curiosity
like what's your real rating because
like your account you don't play a lot
of games on
500 uh somewhere probably between 500
and 600
i don't know wait is it actually you're
debating
you're i wouldn't give away too much i
thought you were busy this was supposed
to be my freebie match i thought you had
like
work to do or something 17 youtube
channels in like a food facility
have you been playing chess all of a
sudden we'll see i i don't want to give
away too much the more i tell you
the more competitive advantage you have
jimmy this was the one match i wasn't
supposed to stress about i came in here
meme i put up ten thousand dollars i was
trying to bait you to put another 10k up
so i could get easy clap 10k
you didn't even fall for it i know i
noticed
ah okay but you're right here i i i will
put up 10k though
we're both going on 10k winner whoever
wins not just one gib but whoever wins
overall gets 10 grand i'll match it
wow sure yeah that's that's fine
games are beginning right now here we go
and mr beast fog champs three presented
by grip six continues
and one e4 and mr beast is stumped he's
taking his time
okay scandinavian all right man
this just i'm gonna have to deal with
john bartholomew all over again the team
scandy hi guys
candy here we go hey guys this is john
all right
we just play scandy here he's gotten his
filthy hands on mr beast's opening
repertoire
he's playing fast too so who is the
better part with all of you
impersonation me or you
probably me
well you need to do more of it you can't
just say two words and then
uh have me award you the bartholomew
medal so
did you not john what do you think about
the scandy you're not seeing my april
fool's video
hi guys i got by starbucks on the way
all right
so really proud of this video and i
wanted to bring it to you guys because
it's about 100 a game series
and uh okay james candy
that was it was decent danny you know
i'll give you a b minus which is
in my in my book is a pretty good grade
e5 though might be yeah that's not bad i
did have some prep look at this scandy
cause if he pushes again here
and i take i'm threatened wallace uh but
it is attacked twice so i'm fine as well
so i'm gonna go here
sticking to the plan if he pushes
i can just take with my pawn it frees it
up to capture because my queen is no
longer being attacked by this rook
castling is an idea i definitely want to
achieve at some point in my lifetime
i mean this is this is a high level game
here and i'm impressed not only with
mr b's preparation but how he's followed
that through he centralized his queen
fundamentals now this is the pivotal
moment danny i really think that the
next couple of moves are going to decide
the game will mr beast
understand the area of the board that he
has to play on that is the king side
he's got to start attacking white's game
he's got to do it quickly both players
now down to five minutes
yeah and that's now he's below five
minutes and ludwig understands the
danger which is a very important thing
if you're playing over confidently
uh you're much more likely to make a
blunder but i'm really really not liking
this this time consumption and he's done
look at him go
that is really impressive danny dude
seriously right he's playing all the
natural moves so
shout out to whatever kind of secret
training uh
jimmy's been getting on on the side
because he's clearly
clearly an underdog here uh surprising
people
he's he is under five minutes so if this
game continues with both them
you know playing the way they are we it
may just come down to time pressure
anyway which is
part of life right we don't play games
that have hours and hours on the clock
anymore at least not in these online
events
so uh we'll see but rook v8 what a move
so interpose i just take oh no i can't
take because the rook
can't even see that
well that's fine we'll wait for his move
before we worry about ours
the flag i still he interposes might
take here
because i still win a rook that's still
a win
i lose a bishop in a knight for a knight
in a rook so
that's not actually that big of a deal
[Music]
i'm not winning a queen boo hoo
carry his position honestly i don't even
know if it's that bad to go takes
takes that might even be good for him
to be totally honest queen sacrifice oh
did i blunder
what no no
you didn't we talked about that budwig
did the right thing when he started kind
of getting aggressive he played c4
even if it wasn't objectively the best
he started attacking uh mr beast and uh
and that was the pressure he needed so i
i i don't think that ludd is going to
blow this at this point he's improved so
much as well
a lot like charlie from pogchamps one
right i just don't think that lubick
doesn't win this game now
i think one of the most impressive
things was that was that uh ludwig
played quickly enough even though he was
getting outplayed so to speak right
jimmy had a better opening
bloodwork was on on his heels a little
bit but he played quickly enough
that um that he was always in the game
right and i think that's a huge sign in
experience right i think players as they
as they play more understand you can't
solve
every problem on every move so you have
to at least give yourself a chance on
the clock and
and then now now not only is he winning
but he's way up on time
well beast grabs the pawn here oh that's
such a good move
that's a beautiful move let's listen in
on lubwig and see if he actually saw the
pin that he's going to mate him if he
takes the rook
king can't move oh wow he did so i
actually pinned his
wow bishop to a mate oh my gosh
and then i'll just do a little doubled
up file
and i'll still go for a big it's a
killer wallop dude i'm super impressed
by ludwig i
obviously i do as much as i can to to
bag on him on a regular basis
no you gotta take your hat
i take with check
um i hmm
i will form up this is flat out forget
[Music]
we can go either here he's not actually
attacking us so this is
pretty irrelevant we just check the rook
look at the confidence now
[Music]
we fork the rope
who is this imposter
what all right game one win this is
oh my gosh this is just nastiness
who is this imposter and what have we
done with ludwig
anyway uh how's it going let's double
check
let's double check double check double
there's only one real reason that you
try to beat mr beasts
and it's for those sweet sweet
subscribers so let's get a live
subscriber count
real time ludwig versus mr beast
what do we have here shirley
surely i am catching up
i have to be
let's take a look any moment now
you're about to start seeing this number
on the left just rocket ship away
ludwig versus mr beasts you know it's
it's like pewdiepie versus t series
pewdiepie versus coco melon
pewdiepie picks a lot of fights d4
we don't see that often in pog jams i
think lubbock's about to pull uh
oh bleep the game has started oops
no maybe not he played d5 and we saw we
saw jimmy give a fist pump there he was
expecting d5 so we'll see
reminder to everyone tuning in these
guys threw down a 10 000
bet started by ludwig on twitter this
morning and uh
beast backed it live in an interview
before the match started so there's a
lot on the line
mm-hmm all right g3 was played this was
the line i was predicting
right with with uh queen h4 check john
did this is oh he finds bishop takes g3
even better
the rook is hanging wow i mean it's just
crazy
and that is just devastation being
wreaked upon black sting that was the
whole point of queen h4 check
and you can just tell by his eyes he has
his eyes are aimed
right at white's king right at white's
king's side and
despite the best efforts of mr beast i
mean blood is just
he's earning this one danny we got to
take our hats off
you know mikhail tall right whom ludwig
tries to model his games after
you know who his favorite uh musical
musical composer was
he was asked once and in a fit of
inspiration he said
ludwig van beethoven
yeah that was i was i was cooking that
up for hours danny
dude so this is my moment in the sun
there's a reason we have bad pun emotes
for you
like on multiple channels ugh i'm
if i make another bad pun my hair myself
might start falling out and then
i'll need a blood wig
who do you want to thank for these i
mean that was pretty good i'm just
oh i'm dying inside and this is my job
to make people feel this way bro
wow who do you want to thank for for how
far you've come with your bad pun game
it's you know it takes a village danny
it takes it takes many people
to allow me to descend to such to such
depths
it's oh really it's taken many years of
practice
oh let's tune into love and see his
thoughts on the final
pain rook check rook defended defended
here must interpose
oh that worked out well
i would say so pre-move it because i
think it's forced
oh my god the queen's
next level stuff we'll check again here
grab pawn
like i said too much among us who is
this imposter
uh we're going for a mate there's a bad
pun for you how's that
the bullet world champion
[Music]
wow instant chess
wow mopping it up here
oh my gosh
[Music]
um holy holy sick oh my lands
oh let's go dude never have i felt so
good on a chess board i
i felt so calm today that was great that
was good chess
oh yes it was
i'm speechless oh my lens i'm speechless
my my throat is dry a lot of people said
that
brain wilson was maybe the clear
favorite to win but you know what dwight
schrute has to say about that
because i could use some nice gaia key
for mate
totally use some of that as well and to
enjoy with some of the park
championships
just made a statement and said rain
wilson is not the favorite and pog
champs will be presented by grip six
white fruit says false and we'll be
right back
next year can you put it where i play
him again first round if we both make it
next year
i'm down next year i will train i'll
give myself a chest coach
i'll learn your first seven moves not
your first six i'll go all out
that's gonna be the game changer all
right one year one year from today
we rematch in chess and we uh we put we
put we put high stakes on it
i'll give you my stream key and you give
me your you just give me your youtube
channel
oh uh yeah you can have like the
reaction channel
we'll do another one later this year
shockingly i think uh
you are like really good positionally
which is like weird
and i am only good like tactically and
so you always got in better positions
but i just don't think you had like
the uh which i think is just a practice
thing straight up i think
if we combine our talents we make one
decent chess player
yeah if yeah that's what i'm saying
that's i'm going to secretly wiretap you
in
on a zoom call for every future chess
match to hopefully help you
have me uh beat everyone blood i i don't
know what to say man i
i don't know who you are anymore like
who is this imposter like what is going
on with you
just keep doing it i guess just studying
a bit
here and there all i gotta say is one
final message to chat
if you guys go out and beat danny's bot
on chess.com he'll give you a free
diamond membership if you screenshot it
instead of proof
everybody let's do it no one can do that
everybody's already beaten your butt and
they've sent it to me i got so many
diamond memberships i got to give away
it's ridiculous
dude i bought trash what do you want for
me just as the plan is simple
and then chokes all right well this
isn't over we're all right
all right blood good luck guys later
everybody you're awesome
thanks guys pleasure to see you we'll
see you in your next match
[Music]
you